IT'S TIME FOR MY RESPONSE.
THAT'S OUR MINI MONOLOGUE.
♪ ALL RIGHT, IF YOU WATCHED
IT SOHIO ON FRIDAY OR YOU
FOLLOW ME ON MY TWITTER FEED
YOU PROBABLY SAW HOW WE TOOK
ON JIMMY KIMMEL WITH
EXAMPLES OF PAST ANTICS
AFTER HE FRANKLY WAS KIND OF
BULLYING THE FIRST LADY IN
MY OPINION WHO CLEARLY IS
NOT IN ANY POSITION TO
DEFEND HERSELF BY MAKING FUN
OF HER ACCENT WHILE SHE IS
ACTUALLY READING TO
CHILDREN.
AFTER WE DID CALL KIMMEL
OUT, HE RESPONDED WITH EVEN
MORE VICIOUS ATTACKS.
ANYWAY YESTERDAY KIMMEL
APOLOGIZED FOR SOME OF HIS
BEHAVIOR.
HE WROTE IN PART BY
LAMPOONING SEAN HANNITY'S
DEFERENCE TO THE PRESIDENT I
DID NOT INTEND TO BELITTLE
OR UPSET MEMBERS OF THE GAY
COMMUNITY AND TO THOSE WHO
TOOK OFFENSE, I APOLOGIZE.
I WILL TAKE SEAN HANNITY AT
HIS WORD THAT HE WAS
GENUINELY OFFENDED BY WHAT I
BELIEVE AND STILL BELIEVE TO
BE A HARMLESS AND SILLY SIDE
REVERENCING OF OUR FIRST
LADY'S ACCENT.
MRS. TRUMP ALMOST CERTAINLY
HAS ENOUGH TO BE WORRY ABOUT
WITHOUT BEING USED AS PROP
TO INCREASE TV RATINGS.
>> Sean: I READ THE APOLOGY
CAREFULLY.
ON THE SURFACE, I WILL BE
HONEST, MORE OF A FORCED
DISNEY CORPORATE APOLOGY
DIRECTED MORE TOWARDS THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY RATHER THAN
ABOUT KIMMEL'S COMMENTS
ABOUT THE FIRST LADY.
BUT, HONESTLY THAT'S
ULTIMATELY UP TO YOU TO
DECIDE HERE.
I BELIEVE EVERYONE SHOULD
ACCEPT POSITION, THAT'S
ACCEPT AOSITION, THAT'S
ACCEPT APOITION, THAT'S
ACCEPT APOLOION, THAT'S
ACCEPT APOLOGIN, THAT'S
ACCEPT APOLOGIES THAT'S
ACCEPT APOLOGIES,THAT'S
ACCEPT APOLOGIES, TAT'S
ACCEPT APOLOGIES, THA'S
ACCEPT APOLOGIES, THAT'S
WHAT MY RELIGION TEACHES ME.
I ASSUME HE IS SINCERE.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I REAL
DELAY ENJOY A GOOD FIGHT AND
I DO AGREE WITH JIMMIE IN
THIS SENSE IT'S TIME TO MOVE
ON.
FOR ME WHAT THIS WAS REALLY
ABOUT NEVER ABOUT HANNITY
VS. JIMMY KIMMEL.
A LOT BIGGER TO ME.
HATRED VITRIOL AGAINST THIS
PRESIDENT AND HIS FAMILY IS
FRANKLY UNPRECEDENTED AS WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT ALL
NIGHT TONIGHT.
THE LEFT IN THIS COUNTRY,
THEY HAVE EVEN ATTACKED THE
PRESIDENT'S WHAT, 10, 11,
12-YEAR-OLD SON.
WHAT'S EVEN WORSE IS WE HAVE
THIS CORRUPT MEDIA
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX.
WE SEE IT ALL WORKING
TONIGHT.
DAILY BREATHLESSLY SAYING
PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING IN AN EFFORT TO
LITERALLY HURT THIS
PRESIDENT AND BRING HIS
FAMILY DOWN.
NOW, ATTACKING THE FIRST
LADY FOR HER ACCENT WHILE
READING TO KIDS IS JUST ONE
SMALL EXAMPLE BUT IT'S A
LINE IN THE SAND FOR ME.
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT MELANIA,
BARRON, THEY ARE NOT
POLITICAL IN THEIR ROLES.
AND THOSE CHEAP SHOTS I'M
SAYING NEED TO END.
NOW, LOOK, I WAS A TOUGH
CRITIC.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN WRITING YOU
ARE A TOUGH CRITIC OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND HIS
POLICIES AND YOU ALWAYS
TALKED ABOUT HIM AND
MICHELLE AND GOING TO THE
CHURCH OF G.D. AMERICA AND
HANGING OUT WITH BILL AYERS
AND BERNADINE DOHRN AND
REVEREND WRIGHT AND SO ON
AND SO FORTH.
THAT'S ALL TRUE BY THE WAY.
I ALSO CRITICIZED MICHELLE
OBAMA'S POLITICAL STATEMENTS
LIKE SHE SAID FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN MY ADULT LIFE I'M
PROUD OF MY COUNTRY?
REALLY?
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
MEDIA IS TRYING TO SAY MY
COMMENTARY OF MICHELLE
OBAMA'S POLITICAL STATEMENTS
IS SIMILAR TO WHAT KIMMEL
SAID ABOUT MELANIA TRUMP.
FRANKLY THAT'S A LIE.
THEY KNOW IT I WAS
CRITICIZING MICHELLE OBAMA
ON THE SUBSTANCE OF HER
POLITICAL COMMENTS.
BY THE WAY, NO ONE WILL EVER
REPORT THAT I HAVE SAID
MULTIPLE TIMES ON RADIO AND
TV THAT MICHELLE AND BARACK
OBAMA SEEM LIKE THEY WERE
WONDERFUL PARENTS.
THAT THEIR KIDS SEEM
WONDERFUL AND THEY RAISED
GOOD KIDS AND THEY DID A
GOOD JOB BECAUSE IT'S NOT
EASY BEING IN THE PUBLIC EYE
AND THAT KIDS SHUT BE LEFT
ALONE.
I SAID IT MANY TIMES.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE AND I
THINK THAT'S A BIG ONE.
UNDER LIKE THE OBAMA
PRESIDENCY, IT SEEMS THEY
HAVE NOT GIVEN ANY COURTESY
BY ANYBODY AT THIS POINT
WHICH PRIEST MY LARGER
POINT.
THE MEDIA IS NOW WHOLLY AN
EXTENSION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THIS SHOW, AND A FEW OTHER
VOICES ON THIS NETWORK AND
TALK RADIO, WE ARE THE RARE
EXCEPTION TO THIS RULE.
LOOK ON YOUR SCREEN, THE 8
YEARS OF OBAMA'S POLICIES
FAILED YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ON A SPECTACULAR
LEVEL.
NOBODY IN THE MEDIA
REPORTED.
THIS AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THE LAST ELECTIONS WAS
ABOUT.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN
OF THIS COUNTRY AND POVERTY
ON FOOD STAMPS AND OUT OF
THE LABOR FORCE.
LIBERAL MEDIA NEVER TALKED
ABOUT IT WE HAVE ENDLESS
STREAM OF LIES, PROPAGANDA,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, CHEAP,
PERSONAL ATTACKS.
MY POINT IS AT THE END OF
THE DAY, IT'S HURTING THOSE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND REALLY
HURTING THE ABILITY OF THE
PRESIDENT EVEN MONTH DO HIS
JOB.
FOR ME IT WAS THE LINE IN
THE SAND.
LEAVE WOMEN AND KIDS ALONE.
I'M DONE.
THAT'S WHY I TOOK ON JIMMY
KIMMEL.
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE THE
THOUGHT POLICE AND I SURE AS
HECK NEVER WANTED POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS.
NEVER SUPPORTED BOYCOTTS.
JIMMY, CONSERVATIVES LIKE ME
THAT SUPPORT IMMIGRATION.
WE ARE NOT ANTI-IMMIGRATION
WE BELIEVE IN LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
JUST AS RESPONSIBLE PEOPLE
CAN DISAGREE ABOUT SOME OF
THE CRAZY THINGS HAVE YOU
DONE IN THE PAST.
I SAY LET THE AUDIENCE
DECIDE.
I HAVE NOTICED BY THE WAY,
JIMMY, YOU SEEM FOCUSED ON
POLITICS.
YOU SEEM SINCERE WHEN YOU
TALKED ABOUT HEALTHCARE, YOU
SEEMED SINCERE WHEN YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
I WANT TO EXTEND INVITATION.
YOU WANT TO COME ON THIS
SHOW, I PROMISE NO NAME
CALLING, NO ANGER NO, REHASH
HASHING OF THE TWITTER FIGHT
HAVE.
TALK ABOUT THE PRESIDENT,
POLICIES, COMEDY, POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS.
ENDING BOYCOTTS, HOW I
SUPPORTED BILL MAHER, HOWARD
STERN, DON IMUS, OPIE AND
ANTHONY.
PEOPLE THAT I DISAGREE WITH
VEHEMENTLY.
MY BET IS YOU WILL AGREE
WITH ME ON A LOT MORE ISSUES
THAN YOU THINK.
FOR MY POINT OF VIEW IT'S
OVER WITH JIMMY KIMMEL.
I MEANT WHAT I SAID, UNFAIR
ATTACKS THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
END TO THIS.
THERE IS NO SHORTAGE BY THE
WAY OF COMEDIC MATERIAL OUT
THERE.
JIMMY, IF YOU DO WANT TO
START UP AGAIN, I PROMISE I
WILL PUNCH BACK EVEN HARDER
AND MY PRODUCER SPENT ALL
WEEKEND COMPILING A LOT OF
LIGHTS IN YOUR CAREER.
THEY DON'T MAKE YOU LOOK TOO
GOOD.
INSTEAD OF AIRING THEM, WE
WILL PUT THEM IN STORAGE AND
WE HAVE MORE IMPORTANT